10,000 Ships is the name of one of the upcoming
Game of Thrones prequels and it's main character
is Princess Nymeria.
Set 1,000 years before the events of Game
of Thrones, the series tells the story of
warrior-queen Nymeria of Ny Sar was who led
the Rhoynar refugees from Essos to Dorne following
their defeat by Valyrian and their 300 dragons.
She’s an ancestor of House Martell and House
Dayne, and is seen as the founder of Dorne
as a unified realm under Martell rule.
Through the marriage of Myriah Martell to
King Daeron II, Nymeria is also an ancestor
of House Targaryen.
After the Rhoyne was conquered by the Valyrian
Freehold, Nymeria led the Rhoynar to Dorne,
where she took Lord Mors Martell of Sandship
as her husband.
After years of war and conquest, House Nymeros
Martell established supremacy over Dorne,
with Nymeria ruling for well over two decades
as the Princess of Dorne.
Through Nymeria's rule, the Dornish adopted
many Rhoynish customs and laws that remain
to this day.
Princess Nymeria was said to be beautiful.
Described by Maester Yandel as strong-willed
and indomitable, Princess Nymeria was said
to have cunning, skill, and wisdom.
Although Nymeria is remembered as a "warrior
queen", and in songs is said to have been
a witch, neither statement is true.
Nymeria is remembered as a warrior-queen,
although she actually was not a warrior herself,
in the sense of carrying and wielding weapons.
She was considered a warrior for being a cunning
military strategist and commander of armies
(comparable to how in his later years Tywin
Lannister was considered a dangerous war-leader,
without actually wielding his own sword anymore).
At the time of the Rhoynish Wars, Nymeria
ruled in Ny Sar, where she had a palace.
The Rhoynar once lived in city-states along
the Rhoyne River.
About a thousand years ago (perhaps 700 years
before the Targaryen Conquest), the Rhoynar
were on the verge of being conquered by the
expanding power of the Valyrian Freehold and
its dragons.
During the Second Spice War, Prince Garin
united the Rhoynar nobility in a grand alliance
against the Valyrian Freehold.
Only Princess Nymeria spoke against him, warning
the other princes that they could not win
the war.
However, other princes shouted her down and
joined their strength to Prince Garin, and
even Nymeria's own warriors were eager to
join his cause.
Despite her own reluctance, Nymeria found
herself forced to join the great alliance.
The war began a thousand years ago when three
dragon-lords from the Valyrian Freehold joined
Volantis in destroying the Rhoynish port Sarhoy
on the Summer Sea.
The Rhoynar responded by uniting under Prince
Garin, the wonder of the Rhoyne who temporarily
made Valyria tremble.
Garin led a Rhoynish army of 250,000, which
conquered Selhorys, Valysar, and Volon Therys,
where they defeated three dragons with Rhoynish
water wizards.
The alarmed Volantenes sought help from Valyria
itself, and the dragonlords' response sealed
the fate of the Rhoynar.
Despite Prince Garin's initial success against
the Freehold, the Valyrians responded by sending
three hundred dragons against the Rhoynar.
Garin's host was shattered and the prince
was captured.
Upriver at Ny Sar, Princess Nymeria learned
of Garin's defeat and the enslavement of her
people, and she knew that her city awaited
the same fate.
In response, she gathered every ship that
remained upon the Rhoyne and filled them with
as many women and children as they could carry—most
of the men had perished alongside Garin's
host.
Rhoynar women were trained to fight as much
as Rhoynar men so Nymeria's army was still
a great force.
While legends often claim that Nymeria commanded
a fleet of ten thousand ships, Beldecar argues
in his History of the Rhoynish Wars that the
number was inflated, perhaps by tenfold.
While other chroniclers offer other numbers,
in truth no count was ever made.
Maester Yandel agrees that Nymeria led a great
many ships, mostly river craft, skiffs, poleboats,
trading galleys, fishing boats, rafts, and
pleasure barges, crammed with women, children,
and old men.
Only one in ten was seaworthy, Beldecar insists.
Nymeria led her ragged fleet down the Rhoyne,
past ruined towns and fields of corpses.
To avoid Volantis and the dragonlords, Nymeria
chose an older channel and emerged into the
Summer Sea where the city of Sarhoy once stood.
The following voyage was long and terrible,
and more than a hundred ships sank in the
first storm they encountered.
As many or more were taken by fear and turned
back, only to be captured by slavers out of
Volantis.
Others fell behind or drifted away, and were
never seen again.
Nymeria's fleet first limped to the Basilisk
Isles, where they paused to take on fresh
water and provisions, only to be descended
upon by local pirate kings.
The corsairs allowed the Rhoynar to settle
on the Isle of Toads in exchange for their
ships and thirty virgins each year for each
king as tribute, although Nymeria refused.
She took her fleet to sea again, hoping to
find refuge on Sothoryos.
Nymeria settled at Zamettar, while others
settled at Yeen or founded new towns.
However, the Rhoynar did not thrive, succumbing
to disease, the dangers of the jungles, attacks
from slavers, and the native population.
After two new towns were sacked by slavers
and the Rhoynar settled in Yeen vanished,
Nymeria summoned her people back to their
ships and they set sail once again.
Nymeria's fleet wandered the southern seas
for three years.
The Rhoynar attempted to settle in Naath where
they were welcomed by its peaceful people,
but they were soon driven off by disease.
In the Summer Isles, the Rhoynar settled on
the uninhabited so-called "Isle of Women"
for more than two years.
The princes of the isles refused to allow
them to settle on larger islands, fearing
the wrath of the Freehold.
However, many soon starved for the island
was poorly soiled and yielded little food,
and disease and slavers took their toll.
Some of the Rhoynar abandoned Nymeria to follow
a priestess named Druselka to return to their
cities along the Rhoyne, only to be enslaved
or slain by their enemies.
Finally, Nymeria turned west and the remnants
of her fleet settled in the deserts of Dorne
on Westeros; the less seaworthy ships settled
the Stepstones or gave themselves up to slavers
of the Free Cities.
Nymeria and her ships finally made landfall
on the coast of Dorne, near the mouth of the
river Greenblood, not far from the Sandship,
the ancient seat of House Martell.
At the time of Nymeria's arrival, Dorne was
a poor land where a score of lords and petty
kings quarreled over rivers, wells, and fertile
water.
Many viewed the Rhoynar as unwelcome invaders
who should be driven back into the sea.
However, Lord Mors Martell of the Sandship
saw an opportunity in the Rhoynar—and singers
claim that Lord Martell also lost his heart
to the beautiful princess.
With many trained in warfare, the Rhoynar
added their strength to Lord Martell's own,
increasing his host by tenfold.
Mors married Nymeria, and hundreds of his
knights, squires, and bannermen wed Rhoynish
women, uniting the two people by blood.
The Rhoynar also brought considerable wealth
with them and their artisans and armorers'
skills were far advanced than those of their
Westerosi counterparts.
To celebrate these unions and to ensure that
her people could not retreat to the sea again,
Nymeria burned her fleet, declaring her wanderings
to be at an end, though some of her people
mourned the loss of their ships.
Nymeria named her husband the Prince of Dorne,
declaring his dominion over all of Dorne.
However, such supremacy was not an easy feat
and years of war followed, called Nymeria's
War.
The Rhoynar and the Martells subdued one petty
king after another, and no fewer than six
kings were sent to the Wall to join the Night's
Watch by Nymeria and her husband.
Soon, only King Yorick V Yronwood remained,
the greatest of the Dornish kings.
For nine years, Nymeria and the Martells battled
against Yronwood and his bannermen.
When her husband fell to Yronwood's sword
in the Third Battle of the Boneway, Nymeria
assumed sole command of the Martell armies.
Two more years of battle followed, but Nymeria
eventually defeated Yorick V and he bent the
knee to her, ensuring Martell supremacy.
Nymeria ruled thereafter from Sunspear, the
new seat of House Martell built around Sandship.
As the Princess of Dorne, Nymeria remained
the unquestioned ruler of Dorne for almost
twenty-seven years.
Dorne was established as a principality, not
a kingdom, for Nymeria preferred the Rhoynish
style of prince and princess.
Alhough she remarried twice to Lord Uller
of Hellholt and Ser Davos Dayne of Starfall,
her husbands served only as counselors and
consorts.
Over the course of her long reign, Nymeria
survived a dozen assassination attempts, quelled
two rebellions, and threw back two invasions
by the Storm King, Durran the Third, and one
by King Greydon Gardener of the Reach.
As Nymeria grew aged and infirm, the armies
of House Martell were commanded by her heirs.
When she at last died, Nymeria was succeeded
as Princess of Dorne by her eldest daughter
by Lord Mors Martell, not by her only son
by Ser Davos Dayne, for Dorne had come to
adopt many of the laws and customs of the
Rhoynar.
The Dornish revere Nymeria as the founder
of their realm, and her descendants in House
Martell continue to rule Dorne through the
present day.
As a result, "Nymeria" actually became a common
name in Dorne (comparable to how "Brandon"
is a very common name in the North, after
their founder, Brandon the Builder).
Oberyn Martell - himself a direct descendant
of Nymeria, warrior-queen of the Rhoynar - named
one of his own daughters Nymeria.
Nymeria's fame also spread across Westeros:
even young Arya Stark, fascinated with legends
about this warrior-queen, chose to name her
direwolf "Nymeria".
Nymeria's life inspired the books Ten Thousand
Ships and The Loves of Queen Nymeria, as well
as the upcoming Game of Thrones prequel series
10,000 Ships.
Legendary characters such as Princess Nymeria,
legendary battles such as 300 Valyrian dragons
fighting Rhoynar and their water wizards,
as well as many battles warrior-queen Nymeria
fought in Dorne, defeating 6 Dornish kings,
all of that and more this Game of Thrones
prequel show, 10,000 Ships, will bring.
Let me know your thoughts about all of this
in the comment section down below.
Thank you so much for watching and I hope
to see you in the next one.
Peace!